and he goes where is the address and he
starts screaming at us and then at this
point I was like listen here all right
you're a horrible driver you had
horrible service shut the f up when I'm
talking he keeps trying to argue with
[Music]
me welcome back to careful Boys the boys
are here
hey clap for ourselves happy New Year
happy New Year um so apparently you got
into a real scuffle with a c taxi cab
driver were you were you punching uh
down or or or punching up I didn't punch
at all I was so proud of myself I um I
didn't hit anybody good job hey
yeah but but David as a self-defense
technique pushed somebody for me are you
sure it wasn't a self offense Technique
No it was okay okay what happened what
happed one of the worst cab driver
experiences ever and I traveled a lot
I've been con by like people I've been
this is was by far the worst and it was
at LAX so me and David um we flew in
from Hawaii yesterday in around like 3 4
p.m. right we get off and then David
parked his car at Tim's place so I was
like okay that's pretty close and he was
like you want to ride back and I was
like yeah sure let's grab a cab and then
you know it's only like you know a
couple minutes away is this like yellow
cab or is like uber lip yeah just a
regular Yellow Cab oh so we walk up and
you know at LAX there's like a direct
like a security director that tells you
like okay that you're in that one you're
in that one which car to go to yeah so
he tells us oh go in that yellow Prius
one and then we're like fine so we walk
up but there was a guy in front of them
like another cab so he got his door open
everything so I was like okay so we just
started putting everything in and then
um we were confused so he was like like
well uh which one are you supposed to go
in right and I was like oh the yellow
one but it's okay I can just we can just
roll with you he goes it's not okay and
we're like what the [__] he goes just a
moment and then he goes up and talks to
security guard whatever comes back is he
the first car or he he's the second car
he doesn't want to be a line cutter oh
is that what happened he was the one be
in the front and then the the yellow car
was in the back so he was already first
in line but the guy was directing us to
go behind him oh but I don't know so I
don't know what was going on I was just
like hey he's next in line so let's just
throw it in but he was already getting
upset so as soon as we get in he goes
where are you going and then we're like
what the [__] like and then David I
don't know the address so David gives
him the address and then he's like oh so
what he kept talking about the Yellow
Cab whatever and we're just like it's
we're past that yeah and then he goes um
again like what's the address and then I
was like David just told you the address
right imagine showing up to like a
surgery table the doctor's like what are
you taking out today but it's in the
file yeah he had a thick ass Eastern
European accent so I was giving him a
pass cuz I was like he probably just
doesn't understand English so he's like
you know frantic I didn't know he was
mad at us I thought he was mad at the
security guy right and then um and again
like he he goes over a row bump he
almost like we're not even out of the
airport at this point there's a speed
bun he goes over and he doesn't let this
other cab through and he's already like
like frustrated at this guy and then he
goes um I like this guy and he turns
around David he goes how do you get
there and then David's like well maybe
if you put the address in your phone and
get the direction you'd know where to go
right real smart right and then under
his breath I hear David going [__]
idiot and I was like laugh so he was
pissed David was already yeah and then I
was like this is kind of weird like I
never had a a cab driver just straight
yell at me as soon as I sat in the car
right that's pretty crazy oh and then
when David tried to go in the uh front
too cuz there was three of us is me
Hannah and David he was like get in the
back like he didn't let him sit in the
front yeah so David I was just like what
the [__] is happening man you guys just
keep taking it from this guy yeah this
guy's bullied before you even left you
just keep taking taking I know I'm like
so these were all the red flags that
probably at this moment I should have
just been like stopped we're getting the
[__] out right but in my head I'm like
Tim's house is a couple minutes away I
think David was on the same page too
we're just like we're just [__] deal
with this and like we're already in the
car so he can't put the address in so he
stops in the middle at at the of the
[__] area where the cabs are all like
going out right and they're all honing
out his ass and he has to get out of the
way and he gives David the phone so
David's like frantically trying to put
in his [__] address and his phone in
in the driver's phone what the [__] cuz
this guy can't [__] do it I was like
you know the thing to do is actually ask
where you know you're going type it in
put your [__] phone up and start
going but he didn't do that he waited
till the last minute to we're like at
the corner of the block he's blocking
traffic he can't even put it in so David
puts in the info and then uh we start
driving right so as we're driving we're
going over the overpass it's it's
telling us to exit he goes straight he
misses the exit he gets pissed off he's
like what the know and he's all looking
at his ey P he's looking at like the
thing he can't see you know what he's
thinking about he's thinking about what
happened before dude he's mad he's human
right so I'm just like all right [__]
dude like I don't know what's going on
but wait how old do you think he is at
this he's got to be late 50s early 60s
he's an old man he's not not he's not
senior but he's like old enough to be
like a grumpy dad right and we have
videos so I'll show you later the whole
time he's like they should have gotten
the yellow [__] guy what I
know hey [__] me Let Go Let It Go just
[__] Let It Go bro he's just like
he's just um cussing under his breath
and just [__] driving erratically
every two seconds he's checking the GPS
and he's like you can feel the the the
nervous frustration out of this dude LAX
is a nightmare do you think he looked up
where the Yellow Cab was going and then
he's taking you guys like like [__]
[__]
guy he misses the exit he gets mad how
was Hannah feeling during this is she
like scared like she this guy's driving
crazy or I think all of us were like
what the hell is this guy's problem so
he wasn't really scary it was more like
hey you need to calm down cuz you're
going to put us in danger but it didn't
get there yet like it was just still the
beginning of like seeing the warning
signs and then we go up you know where
the In-N-Out is yeah he's going the
wrong way right so he has to make a
[__] U-turn to go back the other way
never going to make on the way he goes
where is this place and then David's
like I don't know Los Angeles like look
at the address and then then and then he
goes all right and then he just keeps
going we go southbound there's a Land
Rover that's kind of in front of them
and he's like trying to look over the
window honking and [__] and then when
the uh I guess when the light turns
green he goes up tries to catch up to
him flips him off and he's like [__]
guy two car there were two cars in front
of him that he could have gone up to
this guy's sick dude this guy's kind of
like yeah I kind of love this I like
this guy so this is the point where I'm
I relate to him what the [__] is this
guy like his problem so I I start taking
pictures of his like driver card [__]
you know I took another picture of like
the cab information the company and all
that and I was like all right well I'm
older now I got to be a [__] Ken
right I'm just going to report him and
the cuz for for me it was more like I
got to get this guy off the street cuz
I'm like whatever building your case
once again dude get him off the street
yeah sprinkle some crack in his car know
right plant it's that's true and we were
going under the tunnel and when we got
out the other tunnel out of nowhere this
fool tells David this is Elsa gond not
Los Angeles and David's like cool like
why tell us that like you're so [__]
angry I knew David didn't know L yeah he
doesn't he does it he doesn't dude he's
larps that is we are at the corner of
hawthor Elo and toret this is not Los
Angeles where would you vote where would
you vote huh yeah it's like what the
[__] I'm like what's the point of
telling that follow the GPS dude what
the
[__] so he's like now he's he's driving
like now I think I'm catching up to like
okay this [__] is driving
reckless man and like I don't know how
much longer I want to be in the car with
them so there's a camera going on right
so I'm like oh he has a camera in his
car he has a camera so I was like I
can't punch him in his face or do
whatever it's also dangerous you wanted
did you just reach for start so I wanted
to I was like punch him with the head as
soon as the car as soon as we got to a
red light I wanted to start punching
them in the face and tell him to like
open the trunk so we could get out and
we were just going to get out and
[__] leave right this was like 30
seconds ago Jo was like I'm an older guy
so you know I just want to take a photo
of his like about it I just want to get
him off the streets man you know take
care of everybody else is a danger
reckless driver well I can't do it while
he's driving if I punch him he's going
to go at least you know that now right
that's big no that's that's big boy
stuff funny story though is that uh when
I told about like what my plan was she
goes dang you really matured and I'm
like yeah if this was me at [__] 17 I
would have just wailing on him like and
we're all going to die and I grabbed the
[__] steering
wheel tape his hands to the steering
wheel he can't get
out so yeah at this point I was like
okay if we have an opportunity we got to
like get out or I don't know it just it
just felt wrong right so we pull up just
2 minutes away into this commercial
space and I'm like this does not look
like Tim's house David's on his phone I
think he's just trying to like relax
from the [__] chaos right and I was
like hey David is this Tim's area cuz
I'm looking at the GPS it says we have
to go into that lot and he goes no and
I'm like so this guy busts a U-turn he
kind of parks and then I was like this
is not the place and he goes where is
the address and he starts screaming at
us and then at this point I was like
listen here all right you're a horrible
[__] driver you have horrible [__]
service shut the [__] up when I'm
talking he keeps trying to argue with me
this two star two star okay now down to
one now down to one and I was like what
you need to do is let us off this
[__] thing and then open up your
trunk we're going to get the [__] out of
here he goes you have to pay me oh and
then before I even snapped on him I I
forgot this part but when we got up I I
told David I was like we should have
took a different cab and then he goes
yes take a different taxi you should
take different taxi take the yellow one
yeah to
Bro yell one and I think like he broke
protocol this whole time we were being
nice I think we just didn't raise our
voice we didn't do anything and at that
moment that's when I snapped I was in
his face I was just telling him like one
star yel review [__] I didn't
say yeah yeah but I I didn't threaten I
didn't do bad things I was I I think I
was good on camera did you pay him no I
said [__] that you you don't deserve
anything at all like you put us in
danger I was like you're [__] hor
driver I was like you need to you were
like rude from us you were rud from the
beginning and you're [__] far from
the airport yeah yeah you're still the
end
out yeah and I said why does it take
three times for us to tell you the
address for you to [__] understand
where where to go and then he just
didn't say [__] right so I said get the
[__] out of the car right now and open
up the trunk they got out David and
Hannah were already waiting by the trunk
I stayed in the car cuz I didn't want
this guy to drive off with our stuff
right and then like be spite for
whatever so he goes back there and then
we're back there he wouldn't open the
trunk he's like arguing with us or
whatever so I get into his face and I'm
just like open the [__] trunk right
and then um he does one of these to me
so I I'm like you know trying to grab it
and [__] then David's like come hit us
and see what happens like see what the
[__] happens if you hit us right see
what kind of product you're creating
[__] up I think Dave is a bad guy you
can't give this guy Powers you know but
I'm like why is he trying to be violent
with us at this point it's like threat
let us go right that's crazy yeah and
I'm like and he wants to get paid and
[__] and I'm all like no like this is
ridiculous and you put our lives in
danger what if he just wanted to play
Rock Paper Scissors
yeah you see his other
hand bro he did one of these like like a
little kid like I'm going to hit you you
know damn that's crazy so he opens up
the trunk fck I'm getting all my stuff
right and I think Hannah saw him like
like after that like you know change
positions or whatever so she starts
recing yeah he was going into karate
stands like water stance yeah so I'm
getting all the stuff and then I'm
putting it out right and then I guess
because of the whole fist thing he was
starting to square up to David now oh my
he's getting closer and closer so David
just shoves him he's I want the tall one
and I see this guy [__] go like this
and step back like three times and I'm
like what the [__] like he flew back and
David didn't even go hard he just did
one of these if you [__] your fist back
it does escalate the whole situation
right away even for rock paper scissors
you got to keep it with an eye level you
can't be like like all that D because of
when Hannah started recording this video
is just you guys getting out of a cab
and David pushing the cab literally
that's why I keep that's the context
it's like oh [__] and you see in the
video too that he sees that Hannah's
recording so his demeanor changes as
soon as he sees
he's like yeah he's trying to be a tough
guy like cuz his ego right but then his
demeanor completely changes and then he
gets push he comes back and he goes okay
I leave I leave but then when he drives
off yeah he go like [__] you [__]
[__] she have G the Yellow Cab David's
like you're a terrible person and I'm
like I'm going to be reporting you so
make sure you [__] whatever right
being a carot and he goes um [__] your
mother [__] two times that's what he
said Prett one you think then he get
he's back in the car right he adjusts
the mirror and he's like why are we so
angry existentially yeah a little moment
well I felt kind of bad for him cuz I
think this guy was so impulsive he
didn't realize what a dick he was being
yeah cuz when I started yelling back at
him his face just went blank well cuz
you were the dick exactly like the how
the [__] am I a Dick sh I didn't do
anything and he's I'm at work
so so this is what happened this is what
what happened like he showed us the
phone right and he tried to say that it
was David's fault cuz he's the one that
put the address in I looked at it he had
two routes previously to ours in the
address so then ours was the third route
so when I looked at I'm like it says 19
minutes away look and he wouldn't look
at it he goes you put the address in you
put the address in right and I'm all
like look at the [__] thing it says
the third one dude David added like
eight stops bro it's his fault he's like
go to David doesn't know he doesn't know
David didn't he knows Hawthorn he knows
Hawthorn David put in five addresses and
[__] put it in out dude I was I was in
Europe with Tipsy Bartender you guys
know Tipsy Bartender good guy really
crazy thing we we're getting off of a
plane in [__] I think we're in Sweden
and like we get we get out to the cabs
and they're point us to same [__] they
point us to a yellow C and we're like
okay we get in there and then um we get
in
bags in doors closed he starts driving
we go hey how much is this he just he's
like oh don't worry don't worry don't
worry and we're like how much is this
dude how much is this how much is this
going to cost us dude and he's like
don't worry don't worry we'll work it
out we'll work it out and we're like uh
you need to stop the car we need to
figure out how much we're not going to
get rolled when we get there cuz we know
we're Americans we're juicy little fat
little Target for you and then um and
you have money yeah yeah than you and
then so he he pulls us over we're still
we're like you know how they you know
there's like roads going out of the
airport he just stops in the middle of
the road and then like we take our bags
out and like we're just walking along
the road like so you just dropped you
guys off yeah like you just pulled over
and this like in the middle of snow and
gave up on the fair yeah just completely
gave up it just like got he's like I
can't scam these guys yeah so then so
then we're walking on the side of the
road at the airport right and like
there's cars going by and [__] and uh
and he even was vlogging this [__] and
then there was um cops pull up and like
what the the hell are you guys doing you
can't do this [__] and we're like the
[__] taxi guy like kicked us out or
whatever and then that guy got like
wrecked nice he the cop went to the cops
like went and got him yeah yeah cuz we
had it all cuz Tipsy was vlogging
everything you said the cops didn't go
over there and just like high five them
stupid American
Tourist that's another fishy thing the
guy was doing too he kept resetting his
charge fair thingy and it kept going to
zero I'm like why is he doing that so I
you up yeah he's trying to give me a
free ride dude every time he gets bucks
goes back yeah I don't think I've ever
had a great experience with a yellow cap
ever it wasn't yellow it was a it was a
silver one got the yellow PR maybe it
was like his first day or something you
guys need to like think about was it
like a Crown
Victoria yeah let me see this video
reaction I want to see you guys can see
I want to see the out of context I
failed you Nick my ma my martial arts
master we you just have to be ready for
this dude you got to put your arm up
isn't that the first yeah okay so I'll
let I'll let people hear the back the
that they can hear
it so you could
hear they could hear it but they can't
see Armenian SMR
yeah not get ass in the car now
out Fu get your in the car [__] the car
now get in the
car dude David still got his neck pillow
on and
everything
he's gu jet blue blanket on report you
anyway
go
your he kind of got a sick Whip too he
got that's definitely not a yellow Prius
you guys should have gotten the yellow
Prius dude Shady
vle he's there to pick up somebody else
you know what I mean I think he has a
Type R little am little Armenian Mafia
you know what I'm saying well we are
in raise your fist at me [__] you see
David dude David assaulted old AR
David's wearing Crocs dude David needs
to get reported like you said report
David David we're coming after you way
the way the punch down David Jesus
dude that guy had some scary sunglasses
on though
that yeah dude yeah he had some he
looked like a he looks
connected that's all I say I feel like
he was one of those guys that like he's
just aggressive so everyone he like
freaks everyone out so he like bullies
them that way but as soon as I started
at him in the back seat he just he
stopped but then he still wouldn't give
up like as you guys saw in the video
like he didn't just [__] go no I
think sheving is fine at that
point
especially would have been sick if Joe
crawled behind the guy and got on all
four and then David yeah where the hell
was Hannah there's no teamwork there
that's the move cuz if someone's walking
up to you like that like that's that's
that's you're about to fight and if they
[__] their fist back yeah I don't know
why dude he was going to get [__]
murdered like you know he got some
cousins in AP you guys better watch out
David did kind of like push him into the
street though imagine like he pushed him
in the street in the car D I've seen him
in movies all the time it happens all
the time his shoes fly off me Joe Black
at that point though I was just confused
why he didn't just leave yeah you know
like why is he trying to be a tough dude
you to commit your faces to
memory he's so stupid well we're we're
on the camera so if they decide to
release it you'll see what I actually
said did you guys report him though yeah
yeah his C company is a bunch of
[__] too I called him in I said hey
I'd like to follow complaint I'm like
this is the cab number he goes [__] you
no they can't be him he's at the airport
they said [__] your mother times
two no it's just some [__] s teenager
sounding kid might yeah I said it can't
be him it's it's it's uh not in the
airport I'm like look do you have a cab
with this number 1165 and they're like
yes I'm like okay then that's him and he
goes well he's at X how how do I know
that it's you guys and I'm like I told
you he dropped me off at of alley I
don't that's what I'm saying there's
something fishy about he was supposed to
take somebody else I was like I don't
know where the address is but I'm 3
minutes from the airport so of course he
could be back at the airport what the
hell are you thinking right right and
then he's so stupid he goes C be him
he's at the airport where you're
at elao dud that's a sick customer
service yeah I was like look I'm like if
he drives Reckless and kills someone or
hurts that's your [__] company I'm
just letting you know like what am I
doing here I'm just letting you know if
you want to know this information then
you can talk to him calm him down Joe
you got to know how to car you got to
say can I speak to your
manager that's that's the stone I mean
there's nothing for for I think the real
I'm just going to report to the
Department of Transportation cuz you can
do taxi complaints and if they get
enough they get their uh permit revoked
so damn damn you're really going for it
yeah man this guy was nuts like he knows
how to Ken yeah true cuz look getting
driven around
like it could be a really hard job but
sometimes when people [__] it up and
it's really really bad you're out the
game dude you can't do that anymore yeah
imagine if it wasn't like me and David
imagine if it was like a like two girls
like or Grandpa's that like they this
guy was [__] crazy he can't even put
the the address in the phone yeah he
can't even go to the right location he
can't even understand what's going on
was honking and flipping people off
while driving he almost rear eded
someone and I'm all like
that's I don't know that's 90% of the
job that is a that is a pretty zany
thing like you were thinking where he's
not even really a cab driver he's there
to do a hit yes and you just [__] his
whole thing up and he's just mad he's
waiting for the prime minister of
Malaysia that's why keeps on resetting
the thing he's like [__] I can't get
charged this can't be [__] on paper
know what I mean like aren't you a taxi
yes I mean no I mean yes [__] it let's
go imagine if we did jump up and then
the [__] assassination attempt was
all failed because and they think we're
[__] agents that are like hey not bad
that's a movie that I would definitely
pick up at the and then I'd go
huh double joe7
dude